- At least 49 dead.
- 53 injured.
- Hundreds of lives changed forever
and not for the better.
- But we know this story.
- At what point do we add this to our
list of proud American traditions?
- I don't know.
- I hate to argue, I hate rolling my eyes
at people that I respect.
Hate leaving a conversation
only feeling worse.
So I'll stay out of it.
- [Voiceover] But at least
49 dead and 53 injured.
- There are too many dark days.
Too many heavy hearts.
Too many bodies.
- Too many bodies.
- And I don't know.
I watched my brothers and sisters fall.
- [Voiceover] I turn on the news.
I try to understand but
we fight and we argue.
- [Voiceover] And nobody is to blame
and everybody is to blame.
- Machines are to blame.
- Healthcare is to blame.
- Gods are to blame.
- We are to blame.
But we aren't doing anything.
- We throw opinions like punches.
- Spilling out of our mouths like blood
with our last breath.
But nobody listens.
- Nothing changes.
- [Voiceover] And it happens again.
- [Voiceover] And again.
- And again.
- So tell me, what do I do?
- Do I sign or donate?
Give my blood or my tears?
And what is any of it doing?
- What are we doing?
- I don't know.
- This is not a time for getting defensive
or being offended.
You know what?
I am offended.
- I'm offended that our
children are growing up
in a world afraid of going to school
or the movies or the club.
- That places meant to help us grow
as individuals are being
turned into graveyards.
- I am offended that
this is our new normal.
There is nothing normal about this.
- And yet.
Active shooter in Texas.
- [Voiceover] A family
murdered in New Mexico.
- [Voiceover] Seven
mothers mourn in Chicago.
- [Voiceover] Another
child loss in Maryland.
- [Voiceover] Two more lives in Florida.
- [Voiceover] Another in New York.
- [Voiceover] Another in Louisiana.
- [Voiceover] Another in Arkansas
and that was just one day.
- I am tired of talking.
Tired of praying, tired of
wet cheeks and raw eyes.
- I am tired.
- I'm tired.
- Do we love freely or restrict freedom?
- Do we change our laws or
acknowledge our illnesses?
- Do we crack down or straighten up?
- Or maybe, do we do all of the above?
- Because I don't know much.
But I know I've had enough.